Ants are found on every continent except Antarctica
-- ironic isn't it?
Because you know… the word ant.
It's in the name
and ants are COOL.
HA.
Ants are everywhere, seriously, there are
over 12,000 species of ant, and they just
sent ants to space in the Commercial Generic
Bioprocessing Apparatus Science Insert - 06.
I love NASA.
I'm fascinated by these tiny creatures.
I think they are totally going to take over
the world after we die.
Ants are excellent organizers, they live in
nearly every kind of environment known to
man, and though most of us know there's a
"queen" ant, patrollers, foragers, builders,
and so on, ants are actually egalitarian -- they've
got no leader!
According to the NASA documentation, "No one
ant directs the behavior of a group of ants
and no ant decides what another ant should
do."
They sent ants to space to find out how these
tiny leaderless organizers would handle microgravity!
They did better than we humans did, figuring
out how to float, and then grab the walls
of their container (or each other) very quickly.
Without a leader, ants have to communicate
with each other to complete tasks that help
the colony as a whole.
A study in Nature explored hydrocarbons which
coat ant bodies to keep them from drying out
in desert environments; but they're also used
to communicate.
Patroller ants are usually the first to explore
for food, so researchers drew them out, trapped
them, and then placed tiny glass beads coated
in the same hydrocarbon as the patrollers
outside of the colony entrance.
They hoped this would signal the forager ants
that the patrollers were back, and they could
come get the food they found!
It worked!
This research has implications well outside
of the Honey I Shrunk the Science community…
When engineers and scientists use nature as
the inspiration for technology, it's called
biomimicry.
Honestly, it's one of my favorite things in
science and now computer scientists are proposing
to use ants' de-centralized command structure
to inspire new email spam filters!
Researchers from Stanford realized while observing
ant colonies: young ants are surrounded by
other ants, each with a chemical scent.
Over time,they meet more ants and learn which
are friendly and which are enemies.
As they age, they'll eventually leave the
colony to forage -- meeting strangely-scented
ants which they know to attack, but no single
ant knows every scent, and thus recognizes
every intruder!
In this way, each ant has it's own training
and attack schema.
Rather than training a spam filter with a
centralized master list creating smaller,
broken-up lists allows computer scientists
to make a cheaper, more efficient system.
Studying ants can teach us a lot about the
environment too.
New York City is chock full of environmental
stress for ants (and humans).
Researchers from North Carolina State observed
21 species of ant in Manhattan; and they found
the most common successful Tetramorium Sp.
E has evolved to eat human leftovers!
In nature, ants will seek out sugars, fruits,
meats, proteins, seeds, grains and even other
ant species to eat.
Because they have a lot of human food on the
streets of New York these ants adapted to
clean up after US!They know this, because
researchers found high rates of carbon-13,
a sugar found in corns and grasses common
in human food -- it's rare in their natural
food.
The thing is, other than being super-successful
in this stressful environment, we don't know
what this adaptation will mean for these guys...
Studying ants tells us a lot about the kind
of environment we're creating for ourselves.
Will they fall victim to junk food's woes
like humans?
I hope not...
It's pretty bad out there.
So, ants have no leader, and no formal training
systems on who is attacking versus friendly,
and they eat our garbage and clean up our
streets -- they're a valuable educational
resource to learn about ourselves, our environment,
and through biomimicry, any number of other
scientific inspirations!
What's your relationship with Ants?
Love 'em hate 'em?
You can tell us in the comments below, OR
you can hold onto your comments until April
9th.
Because Thursday April 9 at 2 PM pacific 5
eastern we are going to have a Google Hangout
with Mitchell Moffit and Greg Brown from ASAPScience
and Joe Hanson from It's Okay to Be Smart.
RSVP with the link in the description because
you do not want to miss it.